starting a business is hard I said that
in one of my videos and I got a response
on YouTube from Jared Ellicott who wrote
in this a certain the business is hard
how demotivational he didn't spell
demotivational properly but that's okay
I have my first hater this is great
Jared Jared starting the business is
hard and I wish somebody told me that
when I was starting my company because
the books make it seem so easy do this
do this do this follow the simple recipe
and boom your success it doesn't happen
that way and what it sets people up for
is a huge crash when you're starting
your business the first few months
you're all excited you're running on
fumes everything seems to be exciting
because you're off your passion and then
the crash comes because it starts taking
longer than you thought it was things
are harder than you thought it was gonna
be and you think this isn't gonna work
for me and you think about quitting and
I thought about quitting all the time
every week I thought about quitting with
my first business I was making $300 a
month barely able to survive when my
friends were making a big in the
corporate world because nobody told me
how hard it was a start of business and
I had this major crash and I thought hey
everybody else is having this huge
success
what's wrong with me why can't I make
this thing happen I wish somebody
prepared me for it starting the business
is hard but it's still entirely possible
you can do it and if I'd have been
prepared for it better I wouldn't have
had the big as big a crash and that's
where most people shut down they start
up great ideas great execution we're
going and going going and then you peak
and then you start to go down because
you're not seeing any results
you've got to plow through that your
passion will help you your conviction
will help you your execution your
hardwork your follow-through will all
help you but knowing that it's hard
knowing that that crash is coming will
also help you and I think the worst
advice I could give somebody is starting
the business is easy
because they're gonna look at their own
company and see how hard it is and feel
like a total failure and feel like
quitting starting the business is hard
but you can get through it if you ask
any famous entrepreneur look at any
story and I have the largest collection
a family's not internet profiles
anywhere online read any of them nobody
says it's easy
no entrepreneur says oh yeah I did this
is this and and it was done and it was
great
nobody says that it's not easy but it's
entirely possible after being
demotivational which you can't spell
properly look at any video that I've put
up look at any of the comments and see
if anybody gets D motivated by my videos
I believe in entrepreneurs I think this
is your chance to make a mark to change
the world and to do that you got to put
everything you've got into your business
you got to realize that it's hard you
got to follow your passion and you got
to follow through every day to do
something to grow your business if you
do that you'll have huge success as an
entrepreneur so yeah starting the
business is hard but it's totally
possible believe for those are you
watching please give it a thumbs up
below if you liked the video I'd love to
hear from if you have a comment if you
want to see something a Jared or if
you're another hater leave a comment I
want to hear from you too if you have a
question for your business leave it
below I'll do a video response thank you
guys I'll see you soon
you